In February 2018, Ayesha Khatun got a letter she wasn't expecting.
It was a message from her son Jahat,
written inside a jail in Myanmar's Rakhine state.
She also received a short note from her elderly husband.
It was the first time Ayesha had heard from her 25-year-old son and husband,
since they were arrested by a Myanmar army sweep in August 2017.
The wave of violence had forced more than 700,000 Rohingya, including 50-year-old Ayesha
and her remaining nine children, to flee across the border to neighboring Bangladesh.
After that, Ayesha had no news from her husband and son – until the letter arrived.
During the weeks of violence, soldiers murdered, raped, and arrested thousands of Rohingya,
which the United Nations said military leaders
must face genocide charges for.
Myanmar denies the allegations.
With entire villages razed, Red Cross workers
have said many stuck in Myanmar are desperate
to know if their families made it to the safety
of the camps in Bangladesh.
And like Ayesha, thousands unable to go back are keen to know
if their loved ones survived.
These scraps of paper, carried across borders,
offer a rare source of hope for families.
Between August 2017 and October 2018, the
International Committee of the Red Cross
collected more than 2,400 messages and tracing
requests from people on both sides of the
Myanmar-Bangladesh border.
Red Cross workers have made seven prison visits
in Rakhine to monitor treatment and conditions
of those detained.
Yet all communication in and out of jails
are censored by Myanmar, and that means letters
are limited to family news –
the notes written down by Red Cross workers
in English and Burmese.